welcome back to las vegas now did you
guys know that there's a secret season
around the corner that's perfect for
houseboating and lake activities i took
a road trip to lake mead mojave
adventures the sponsor of this next
segment to learn more take a look
i'm chad taylor with lake mead mojave
adventures and we're here at the
beautiful cottonwood cove marina today
to talk a little bit about
our six houseboat models and the
beautiful end of summer and the
beginning of the secret season which is
september and october where the weather
stays warm and the water hasn't cooled
off yet there's two places you can rent
houseboats here in southern nevada one
is lake mead at caldwell bay marina and
the second is right here at cottonwood
cove marina on lake mojave to rent a
houseboat
typically you're sitting in the office
ready to get out for the weekend or even
maybe you're off during the week so you
call up some friends and you say hey
let's get out to the lake how do we rent
one of those houseboats well first of
all we've got a local call center with
mostly local agents pick up the phone
we'll walk you right through it we'll go
through pricing we'll go through
scheduling we'll go through availability
and we'll actually teach you how to
hospital from start to finish we offer
six different types of houseboats
starting from the smallest houseboat
which is about 50 feet up to the largest
houseboat that is about 75 feet all of
our models will fit anywhere between 8
and 12 people or sleep 8 to 12 people
comfortably
doesn't mean there can't be more once
the boat's parked
with some blow up mattresses but
generally speaking it's 8 to 12. you
have full amenities like you would in a
small apartment as you see that's the
first queen room
back of the boat
two separate bedrooms down below both
queen size as well
the whole fan full restroom
nice shower yes stand up shower
absolutely water tank 500 gallons
refrigerator of course full kitchen
microwave toaster oven
trash compactor in case you didn't feel
like doing it yourself okay so we just
took a tour through the living quarters
and now we're on my favorite part of the
hospital this is the rooftop deck right
so what can we do up here well first of
all you got a small refrigerator up here
so you can make sure you bring all the
drinks upstairs exactly secondly you
have a slide off the back
uh you have a place where you can drive
and control the stereo from okay or if
you just music is a must up here yeah
absolutely i'm picturing it now or just
throw out the lawn chairs and relax and
let that breeze go from 110 degrees into
90 degrees as you stand under here it
feels so good up here and so if i if i'm
you know
inviting my friends down for a houseboat
trip
how much is it going to cost us can we
all just split the cost
yeah great question i'd split the cost
for sure yeah you can get a houseboat
for uh
right now kind of going into the secret
season you can get a houseboat for
probably about as little as about 600 a
day all the way up to a couple thousand
dollars a day so depending on the size
of houseboat you want and how many
friends you want to bring you can
determine that okay chad speaking of
secrets
where am i parking this houseboat
what codes are we going to that's a
great question so
there's one
of a hundred
that you'll have to come out and find
because adventure's in her name all
right speaking of adventures now i think
it's time to get on the slide right
we can't be up here without getting on
the slide no swimming in the harbor
rocky
all right fine chad thank you lake mead
mojave adventures for sponsoring this
segment you can find them in search like
nevada and for more information just
call
855-918-5253 or visit
lakemojaviadventures.com
hey